6 actu avec mon vincent vinel qui fera
la tournée bien sûr de the voice
la tournée en france et en belgique du
18 juin au 7 juillet et on va regarder
la bande annonce tout à l'heure mais je
pense que ça va être formidable parce
que il y avait des très très gros talon
encore cette année on dira ce qu'on
voudra franchement des talons géniaux et
c'est qu'à gagner avec lisandro mon vin
sans merci d'être là il va nous chanter
les passants d'accord à vous de trouver
de quelle actu on parle
vincent c'est à toi c'est parti mais oui
allez allez je suis maire s'est fait
jeudi
alors enfin michel cymes qu'est ce que
c'est que l'actu du jour
en fait enfin c'est un peu oui
enfin michel cymes oui sa maison à la
brûler
[Rires]
ok
n
sophie
à essayer remplacer
oblath et baky
[Musique]
quelle est leur fond moi j'aime bien
j'ai envie qu'ils l'auront pas et moi
aussi
anne-sophie mêmes eaux
anne
sophie a été remplacé
a été remplacé
imaginez si on était musulmane juive et
si on mettait vincent vinel mais dans
les matchs de foot
un changement 20h20 heure pour annoncer
le chômage
siro
là bas aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en direct
[Musique]
alors ça parle d'un pierrot pierre
s'équipent hier pierre pierre perret est
repéré l'ancien meilleur mais nécessaire
pas d'armé mais ça m'a d'ailleurs pas le
mode
c'est toujours très long et entre
[Musique]
j'ai vu
je vais vous parler de transmettre
adieu
il appuie dans les dom
[Musique]
le patron faire après
[Rires]
ils sont plus longs que les chansons
[Musique]
avec
la dea sur twitter
alors qui est libre qui est libre
capitaux va pas est pas possible non max
sur twitter elle est célibataire en ce
moment à la sidr
bravo très bonnes réponses
c'est mimi mathy
[Musique]
voilà je me suis perdue en fait du coup
je me suis dit on va combler attend à
merci oui ça va t'aider
ouais si moyen des concerts musicaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors elle va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dans la musique qu'est ce qu'un
caisse 4 pourquoi mimie mathy ne veut
pas faire fort boyard là parce qu elle a
peur qu'on apprenne pour passer partout
vous avez bien d'écouter
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle émission
avec des chiens des chats
[Musique]
parce qu'il est italien
fin
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
et j'adore
invitation aux yeux en fait pour santé
du choc irak font bâiller les gars comme
ça j'aime bien parler comme ça sinon je
sais pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]